hey everyone I'm Lucy and joining me
today is Marcus Leto president and game
director over at v1 interactive on
desintegration Marcus hiding I'm doing
well thanks Lucy it's nice to be here so
people know you obviously from your work
on the Halo franchise a few years ago
when you're working a Bungie but then
you kind of left the triple a life
behind went into a more independent game
development lifestyle where and when
were the seeds of disintegrations so
when did you know that you wanted to
move away from halo from that franchise
and make something else and it wasn't
actually too long after I left Bungie I
kind of did some exploration here and
there I looked at big triple-a games and
little mobile games and a lot of
different types of game universes for a
while I spent about two years before I
finally landed on this one idea that had
I had kind of had some sketches for as
far as the fiction is concerned I kept
coming back to it as something that
really interested me and the more I come
back to it the more and intrigued I was
with the universe and the capabilities
that it had and so I decided just to
actually start putting some effort into
building a prototype around that idea
I'm a big sci-fi fan and I think for me
the thing that draws you in to a
particular piece of sci-fi is the world
that's been created so it's really cool
to know that like that was the seed for
it wasn't the gameplay it was creating
this universe can you talk a little bit
more about what the state of the
universe would be as you load into this
integration so the fiction of the story
is set about a hundred fifty years from
now it actually when I while I started
the fiction for this over six years ago
one of the issues that I was dealing
with in this fiction was that humanity
was being pitted against several
different issues that were creating some
severe difficulties and potential
extinction event as well so that was
something that as a result of these
these issues that humanity was dealing
with that taking the actual brain from a
human and integrating that into a
robotic entity was a means of survival
it was it was really meant to be a
temporary solution until real solutions
could be solved and that brain could be
reintegrated with a clone version of
their body and they could become human
again that's the that was that the the
big rosy picture that they painted for
themselves but that didn't work the way
they had planned and so in this future
those that have been integrated some of
them decide to split away and become
this militarized force and they don't
want to become human again
but you and a group of other folks like
you decided to fight back and and
separate from that enjoying with the
natural humans and be part of that you
know that part of humanity is so
important to them and that's who we play
in this game that's where our section
our fiction is set in the future and
that's where we really dive into the
individual characters within the world
and the interest that they have with one
another so I was playing a little bit
last night I was playing through some of
the single-player and what I really
liked about it is that between the
missions and before we get on to the
gameplay itself there are these moments
of respite where you're sort of walking
around I guess your home base and you're
chatting to everyone and just getting
these snippets of the law where did that
idea it reminded me actually of Mass
Effect a little bit you do a mission
then you check on everyone because you'd
want to you want to build up that
rapport with your your crew where did
that come from and how did you start to
build out this crew this motley crew
that you're hanging around with yeah to
that event like we wanted the between
missions for the player to be able to
just come back to a home base a place
where they could you know feel comfort
take a breather get to know some of the
other characters uh it's a it's an
optional kind of thing for the player to
do where they can interact with some of
the other story characters in that
environment and get
little bit more in information from them
about what their motivations are and
such when it comes to those characters
each one of them are like I was saying
there they're unique individuals then
they're not genetically modified super
trained super soldiers or anything like
that they're just normal folks like
journalists teachers mechanics game
developers maybe who knows you know
there's others normal people who are
pitted under extraordinary circumstances
with a will to survive and it's these
characters that while they come from all
walks of life they have this common you
know bond pulling them together this
will to survive and to one day become
human again and so at the beginning of
the game we escaped from the enemy the
Ray on enemy in our game and we are kind
of just pulled together with this group
that they have to get to know each other
and how to work with one another and how
to trust one another throughout the game
and that's where the crux of all the
interesting stuff happens between them
so you've kind of flushed out this world
and you're flushing out these characters
let's talk a little bit about the
gameplay because it is this hybrid of a
first-person shooter if you want it to
be like you're controlling the graph
cycle or it's an RTS essentially you're
commanding units where did that idea
come from
the game actually started out as
strictly an RTS type game it was very
standards banned select micromanage
units on the ground all set within this
universe but it wasn't too long into
that development of a prototype very
very early prototype that I said to
myself this is just never gonna stand
out amongst the sea of other games that
are like this and while I liked what we
were creating I like the simulation of
combat on the ground that was one of our
primary focuses of making that really
interesting to watch
I decided that we needed to do something
dramatically different so it wasn't it
was one of those things late at night
you know when you wake up in the middle
of the night with a with an idea and
this one was turning that camera in the
sky into an active participant in combat
like giving that the player the agency
to involve themselves fully in what's
happening in gameplay so we turned that
camera into a vehicle we now call a grav
cycle and you're the pilot of that graph
cycle with onboard offensive and
defensive weapons but you're also then
commanding those ground units and it
required us to completely rethink how
you can interact with those ground units
in a way that doesn't overwhelm the
player and is in keeping with the
fluidity of that first person shooter
mechanic and so that took us quite a
long time to iterate on that gameplay
cycle and really hone in and find that
core nugget that was just golden that
turned into something really cool and
special that took us a long time to
finally get to a place where we were
excited and comfortable you know with
the with the Corps combat loop and those
core gameplay mechanics but because
there's nothing else out there like this
so we couldn't go chase the tail of
another game we had to invent all new
Mechanics for how that works and and I
think we got it down to this this really
nice fluid of gameplay experience that
while it's a little hard to describe I
think once players jump into the game
and get a get a hands-on experience with
it I think they'll really appreciate
what what we've created it's a strange
thing to have to pitch to people because
you're you can pitch to the RTS crowd
and you can pitch to the first person to
to crowd but you can also encourage them
that you can you could swap sides you
can do either one what what was the
moment can you describe the moment where
things clicked in terms of the gameplay
it it took some time when we were going
through this iteration cycle of trying
to figure out how
to command those ground units initially
we were still trying to allow
micromanagement of them and it wasn't
until we said let's just let go of that
and let's boil things down to their bare
essence the most important parts of what
we really want to get across and then we
we got to this point where we turned
that ground crew into a more into a
solid entity themselves like it might be
as few as two ground units and as as
many as four each of whom have a unique
ability that you can use tactically in
gameplay but we wanted to make sure that
they did smart contextual things on the
ground based on your decisions that you
give them your commands that you give
them and we do that through a command
pulse and it was the invention of this
command pulse that literally fires out
of your graph cycled down onto the
ground you can position them in the
environment using that you can target a
priority target and enemy you can even
select objectives within in the
environment such as things that they
need to interact with for story purposes
or for picking up stuff like Salvage in
the game that you use as a currency when
you come back to that home base and so
it wasn't until we got to that point
where we started really honing in on how
that mechanic works and how smart those
AI needed to be on the ground then
finally it all began to click and we
knew that I think we were getting to the
homestretch then of what we needed to do
on the design side so you said you had
this idea six years ago what was the
process like of building the team to
execute the idea it took a while because
I didn't want to go to a publisher and
do a whole bunch of hand waving and
smoke and mirrors or just a PowerPoint
presentation saying hey it's just me and
I'd like to build a studio and this game
idea so I hired a couple college
students who were still in their senior
year
and to help me out on the engineering
side and we took our time to slowly go
through this process of building a
prototype that we could use as a solid
example for the design mechanics and for
the overall intent of what we wanted to
do with the game that made it a lot
easier for us to start pitching it
around to publishers like Microsoft and
Sony and such but it wasn't until I met
one of my old colleagues from Bungie his
name's Alan and Alan and I met for lunch
and he was starting to work with this
new publisher out of New York part of
take two they hadn't named themselves
yet and they were like he's like I think
you should pitch the game to to to our
group because what you're doing what you
want to do is build in moderate size
tripl a quality game with a small team
that has the highest quality possible--
and a modest budget and that's exactly
what they were looking for so it was
kind of like this perfect union of my
and and perfect timing you know for for
us to meet up with him and for us to
then get involved with private division
which was ultimately the what the studio
or the publisher called themselves and
and it took a while you know we had to
go through a greenlight process even
with them of proving that we could grow
our team I could hire on a handful of
other people that I know from the
industry as well as hire a brand new
talent straight out of school and so
while we were only like 10 to 15 people
for a majority of the development time
it's not until just this last year that
we've grown to about 30 people now so
last question I mean if you were to go
back and see yourself six years ago and
say you know we're on the cusp of
disintegration coming out now what would
you tell yourself and what are your
hopes for the game for the studio I
wouldn't have believed that we would
have gotten this far already
it seems like it's been a long time but
I initially was planning on the studio
being super small and us being like this
teeny little indie boutique thing I am
so happy and so proud for how the studio
has evolved over the course of the last
three and a half years to where we have
grown with such great talent and we have
built such an amazing game in my opinion
of course I'm really proud of what we've
created together we took a leap of faith
to do something completely different and
new and it was a challenge for sure it
was not easy and it still isn't easy as
we try to wrap up the game amidst a
global pandemic and everybody is working
from home so it's a really interesting
time for us this is certainly one of
those most memorable dev cycles I've
ever been in that is one for the history
books for sure but we made it work and
I'm really really happy and proud of v1
the studio and uh and what we've been
able to create as a result thank you so
much Marcus for more on disintegration
make sure you stay tuned to game spot
and don't forget we're running play for
all all summer for about the next six
weeks or so talking about all the newest
game announcements as well as doing a
charity drive for black lives matter and
Direct Relief there will be donation
links below
you
[Music]